notre invité politique ce matin c'est
génial vert bonjour beaucoup d'être avec
nous députés les républicains de
vaucluse une région animé en ce moment
on va bien sûr en parler en détention
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour cassel bertrand
bonjour bonjour bonjour qu'est celle du
groupe la dépêche
on va évidemment commencer par la
qualité de votre parti et de votre
région julien baer après un feuilleton à
rebondissements les républicains ont
donc à nouveau hier soir réitéré leur
soutien à renaud muselier président
l'est républicain sortant de la région
sud provence alpes côte d'azur est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec la décision
de votre parti vous dis c'était quoi le
problème
revenons le problème c'est un premier
ministre qui est sorti dimanche en
disant voilà avec le président de la
région nous allons recomposer la droite
pour résumer et y aura une alliance avec
en marche des ministres ministres des
députés des sénateurs doug grande
confusion dans notre électorat des gens
qu'ils menaient alors finalement elle
est réelle rmc la même chose au final
qu'est ce que nous avons eu hier soir
nous avons un accord économique presse
où il est dit très clairement n'y a pas
d'alliance non il n'y a pas d'accord il
n'y aura pas de députés et de sénateurs
de la république en marche où il y aura
des députés les sénateurs les
républicains donc pour moi les choses
sont très claires c'est à dire que c'est
un une rebuffade
et voilà en disant merci pour votre
soutien éventuel monsieur prémices mais
nous ne voulons pas participer à cette
recomposition
je crois que c'est essentiel parce que
l'objectif de la macro ni dans ce
dispositif c'était pas la région c'était
tout simplement de dire en 2022 il peut
y avoir que deux candidats marine le pen
et moi eh bien non il ya bien un partie
qui résiste encore et toujours à
l'envahisseur
ils s'appellent les républicains il a
ses faiblesses il ya ces ambiguïtés
parfois mais il est très clair il était
très clair hier soit en disant que non
ça n'était pas l'objectif qui était
poursuivi qu'on devait mener une
élection régionale donc pardon vous êtes
vous qui avez été assez dur hein
dimanche lundi avec avec la décision de
renaud muselier
vous avez même dit un mot vous ne feriez
plus campagne à ses côtés ça veut dire
que ce matin vous re fait campagne à ses
côtés vous soit sur la vie moi je sais
ce que j'ai toujours dit c'est j'attends
mardi si renaud muselier devait
confirmer qu'il est une alliance avec en
marche si bien dans ce cas là ce sera
sans moi appartement ou dit non il n'y a
pas d'alliance avec en marche vous savez
moi je suis un homme de simples j'essaye
pas de chercher midi à quatorze heures
oui je ferai campagne évidemment pour
renaud muselier qui non je suis
conseiller régional sortant et qui a un
bon bilan je le rappelle donc vous serez
sur la liste après j'espère être sur la
liste
il m'a en tout cas dit vous l'a pas dit
bassil a dit que les députés c'est à
tort serait sur la liste mais là encore
je le laissais faire sa liste
on avait de comprendre qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant la journée d'hier
noomiz ollier a fait marche arrière vous
lui avait demandé de faire marche
arrière par rapport aux discussions
qu'il a fait à voir avec elle à m
non c'est à dire que on lui a demandé de
clarifier parce que il ya j'irai donc
dans un vocabulaire régionales il ya une
volonté de rassembler et on en a besoin
parce qu'il y à leur assemblée nationale
d'un côté parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne se retrouvent pas dans les
partis politiques
et parce qu'en plus la majorité sortante
est assez pluriel donc
renault avait en avait souhaité montrer
qu'en réalité
eh bien il était l'homme très large d'un
rassemblement
voilà et ils voulaient additionner des
compétences etc sauf que ce discours
à partir du moment où le polémiste
donner une autre interprétation qui
était dit ça signifie en réalité vous
fusionner avec en marche
c'était létale et donc nous avons eu un
débat d'abord parce qu'il a fallu qui
s'explique aussi en interne sur pourquoi
comme on en était arrivé là qui donne sa
version
parce que sa version c'était en tout cas
que c'est pas lui qui a parlé c'est jean
castex et deuxièmement qu'on soit
d'accord sûr si on était bien au clair
sur les choses et donc
effectivement ça a permis d'arriver à ce
texte très clair ou voilà on a tranché
mais sauf que renommés lee lui l'a
jamais vraiment changé de version ça
fait des semaines qui dit qui composera
sa liste sur le plan local et pas sur le
plan national que la politique nationale
lui ça l'intéresse pas qu'il est ouvert
au plus large rassemblement possible il
avait même parlé d'un test pcr programme
confiance république lyon dans
l'impression qu'il n'a pas changé de
discours
est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu un peu sur
réaction chez les républicains est ce
que vous n'avez pas réagi trop vite
dimanche notamment christian jacob est
ce qu'il aura fallu attendre la journée
d'hier non jeûneurs je ne crois pas même
ce alors moi j'ai toujours dit je pense
que la réaction de christian jacob était
était obligatoire parce que ne pas
répondre on s'était donné l'impression
que jean castex bien avait avait avait
clôt le débat que nous acceptions la
chose
nous avons eu des milliers de gens
d'adhérents de des lecteurs qui nous ont
dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
choses au delà de paca au delà du
vaucluse là-dessus pardon pardon je
serai président d'eads sud et donc la
décision de christian c'était très clair
c'était de dire non non pasaran
ça ne passera pas et puis en charmant
qui connaît bien renaud muselier qui
avait discuté avec lui lorsque les
journalistes me disait exr jeudi
attendait mardi attendait mardi
attendons parce que j'allais vous avez
les gérer les échanges dans la presse
les interprétations qu'on fait à un
moment donné il faut être clair voilà
pour moi c'est pour ça que je souhaitais
ce moment de vérité d'ailleurs il l'a
reconnu lui-même que à aucun moment moi
j'ai si vous voulez utiliser des mots
blessants
parce que il faut bien prendre
conscience que il ya quand même notre
vrai adversaire
c'est effectivement la gauche et thierry
mariani que notre meilleur candidat
c'est renaud muselier voilà donc je suis
très content en tout cas soulager même
que se soit passé comme ça parce que le
temps que je n'ai pas réponse mardi
peut-être qu'effectivement il aurait pu
dire maintenant c'est vrai voilà mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire pas de
candidat de la république issue la
république en marche sur les listes
elles errent dans la région pas de
parlementaire qu'est ce que ce qui
marque et c'est à dire personne dans
marche personnes
une ambiguïté la veille en dix ans aucun
parlementaire me sifflent les sortants
comme moi n'était pas sur la liste ont
il a bien clarifiée non les en marche le
long c'est l'alcool non l'eau
ferrugineuse oui l'alcool n'ont donc
l'ailé en marche non les lèvres oui sauf
que vous avez entendu hier gabriel atta
le porte parole du gouvernement lui dit
qu'il y aura des marcheurs sur la liste
de renommer changé qu'est ce que je veux
dire ma voisine aussi
non mais à un moment donné non mais que
le gouvernement si vous voulez agissent
comme une amoureuse éconduite en disant
mais non mille même ça je vous pourrez
jamais l'empêcher d'arriver ce qu'ils
ont tenté de mettre une bombe à
fragmentation sur le moteur de la droite
accueillait on leur a dit non ça c'est
le premier point
et puis deuxièmement effectivement ils
ont retiré leurs listes parce que ce
qu'avait dit renaud muselier c'était le
bon sens serait qui ne présente pas de
liste et qui me soutiennent et moi
j'avais plaidé pour le soutien sans
participation faut être logique
si vous êtes fin on a brisé la nuit qui
n'arrive pas dire mon ennemi c'est
madame le pen bon donc en région prend 5
a des yeux il constate que les risques
il dit je présente quand même une fille
je la retire pas bon d'être dans ce cas
là il ya une contradiction non
maintenant ils ont retiré leurs listes
s'ils sont pas contents ils peuvent
faire une liste s'il tentait qu'il
puisse la faire parce que pour l'instant
sur le terrain j'ai dit oui vous savez
c'est un parti un peu fantomatique et
sophie cluzel renaud muselier vous a
garanti que ce fait que les amis ne sera
pas sur la liste vous parlais juste de
bombes à fragmentation est ce que quand
même le gouvernement il a pas un peu
réussie parce qu'on voit par exemple la
réaction d'eric ciotti eric ciotti c'est
quand même une personnalité dans votre
région sud pour lui s'oppose à cette
décision il ne fera pas campagne pour
renaud muselier est ce que le
gouvernement n'a quand même pas réussi à
fracturer votre parti dans votre région
parce que c'est une question alors moi
je peux pas parler pour eric ciotti mais
je pense que dans une famille politique
à un moment donné et surtout normal dans
une même région
moi je fais confiance je trouve que
chacun ses valeurs j'ai dit lorsque il
ya eu ces nouvelles j'ai dit moi je suis
prêt à me couper une main tant pis pour
mon fauteuil
voilà c'est pour mes idées parce que les
gens ont toujours l'impression qu'on
s'accroche si vous voulez à des postes
pour des prébendes et des émoluments
je voulais que ce soit très clair et en
même temps je fais confiance
parce que si vous n'avez pas confiance
si vous dites
araud nommé les goudes tu as pris tous
les engagements mais malgré tout ceci je
te refuse d'investiture dans ce cas là
ça veut dire en réalité qui a pas
d'accord possible et on perd notre temps
donc moi je fais le pari de la confiance
parce que ça fait des années que je
connais renaud muselier
ensuite il ya eu ça vous aura pas
échappé des mots très durs
donc il y avait effectivement des
réalités humaines
bon donc ça va laisser des traces on va
laisser des traces maintenant le
principal perdant aujourd'hui c'est
quand même en marche qui a envoyé son
premier ministre pour annoncer un accord
qui deux jours plus tard l'accord tombe
et qui se retrouvent sans accord et sans
liste des kids ont maintenant on se
retrouve face à un problème
faut-il faire une liste alors qu on a
annoncé qu'on le retire et qu'on le
soutenaient comment et dans quelles
conditions
mais si j'ai un regard si cette histoire
prend une ampleur nationale aujourd'hui
c'est aussi peut-être parce qu'elle est
symbolique de ce qui risque de se passer
à la proche de 2022
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que les
uns après les autres les gens de votre
famille politique soit approché ou par
la république en marche ou par le
rassemblement national pour d'autres et
qu'elles se reproduisent comme ça je
vais leur jeter la présidence je pense
que ça aura servi d'exemple là il ya une
tentative de l'enlèvement des sabines 1
et nous avons collectivement répliqué
donc et ont d'ailleurs je crois que tout
le monde aura constaté que ces
stratégies n'a pas donné un résultat on
n'a pas eu des fleurs et quand jean
castex a dit j'apporte mon soutien
la population de provence alpes côte
d'azur s'est pas soulevé dans tout le
pays en disant super quelle bonne idée
c'est la recomposition nous attendons
c'est pas du tout ça qui s'est passé et
puis deuxièmement que les gens de droite
se rassure il ya des gens qui ont
résisté
il ya des gens qui ont contrairement à
ce que dit leur assemblée nationale qui
dit mais ils sont tous pareils non mais
monsieur mariani l'a reconnu moi je suis
droit dans mes bottes
ce matin je peux vous dire sur votre
plateau j'ai aucun problème et je le dis
d'ailleurs aux gens qui n'ont rien si en
2022 emmanuel macron tente de faire la
même chose il y aura des gens qui
résisteront comme bruno retailleau comme
laurent wauquiez que voilà bon en tout
cas les choses sont claires après je ne
peux pas parler pour ceux qui voudraient
ne pas être clair il y en a peut-être
quelques-uns dans ma famille politique
peut-être que les choses se clarifieront
mais la majorité la très grande majorité
l'extrême
on était 2 hier du bureau politique est
unanime mais pas la totalité comment ça
s'est passé concrètement chef d'euros
politique hier soir julien baer vous qui
étiez le bureau de la commission de
l'investiture n'ont pas écouté il ya eu
d'abord une présentation très solennelle
de christian jacob pour expliquer les
enjeux une réponse de renaud muselier
qui s'est engagé sur ce que proposait
laissant jacob ensuite quelques
interventions des changes
et puis après effectivement quelques
interventions sur les interventions de
questionnements dont ça a été tendu
nous venons cds et s était pas tendu non
alors il ya eu un moment donné
effectivement une passe d'un parce que
entre christian estrosi peut-être et
certains membres de la commission dans
la relation est pas la même que celle
avec renaud muselier mais je savais que
si on imagine voilà voilà à bord on vous
imaginez mais j ai été assez rester
urbain poli et civilisée personne n'a
quitté la salle il ya des divergences je
dirais que tout le monde connaît de
stratégie bon moi je veux retenir s'il
voulait qu'à la fin ben voilà il ya eu
sur peut-être oui c'est 4 5 personnes
qui estiment pour des raisons x ou y
et puis le reste a voté et c'est ça bien
l'essentiel c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons un candidat soutenu par les
républicains qui a pris un engagement
clair et je sais qu'il le respectera
je pense que le 17 mai nous pourrons
pour tous le constater si on arrive à
cette situation j'ai bien verrez ce que
c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas de leader
incontestable et qui tiennent la famille
aujourd'hui chez vous il faudrait me
donner beaucoup plus d'une minute
parce que ça fait depuis 2008 16 que je
le dis assez parce que nous n'avons pas
fait l'inventaire des années chirac et
des années sarkozy et tant que nous
n'aurons pas dit aux français voilà ce
que nous avons raté bien nous
n'arriverons pas à avancer
deuxièmement parce que nous n'avons
effectivement pas de chef battu rennes
et donc ça nous avons besoin d'un
système de départager puis troisièmement
parce que l'ump a été créée à l'origine
en disant on va occuper tout le spectre
sauf que ça marche quand vous êtes au
pouvoir que vous êtes dans l'opposition
les gens veulent de la clarté ils
veulent savoir où vous êtes et nous
aurons besoin d'eux
de revenir sur nos fondamentaux voilà
pourquoi j'ai créé un mouvement qui
s'appelle osé la france est concrètement
sur les fondamentaux c'est le gaullisme
c'est que ça veut dire qu'il faut
revenir un parti gaulliste et un parti
centriste ou à bombay le parti centriste
et monsieur macron aujourd'hui qui veut
qu'ils essayent de france sait pas très
bien où il est d'ailleurs même si vous
avez des centristes qu'ils n'aiment pas
emmanuel macron la vraie pour pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'est pas ma chronique
parce qu emmanuel macron en réalité n'a
pas d'objectifs collectifs il parle aux
individus ils parlent de leur réussite
individuelle de leur singularité il
ailleurs c'est un des constructeurs n'en
perdra peut-être plus tard et moi je
prends la nation et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on doit sauver
c'est la nation française
la différence avec marine le pen c'est
marine le pen parle de la nation mais
comme fermeture moi je suis pas dans la
nation pour la ferme et je suis pas pour
fermer les frontières et dire la
mondialisation n'existe pas elle est là
la mondialisation en réalité vous vous
en créer dans une culture nationale
parce que ça vous permet en france de
devenir universel c'est bien parce que
vous comprenez clovis victor hugo
napoléon que vous êtes fier de
l'héritage qui vous a été donné que vous
savez parler à des italiens des
espagnols etc et pas je suis une espèce
de citoyens monde qui n'a pas de maison
ça c'est je dirais des mondialistes que
je combats et deuxièmement ça n'est pas
non plus le village d'astérix en disant
moi je cultive une identité renfermé
consista à nous dire ne peut-on pas au
bout de votre raisonnement julien vers
ça veut dire que dans la situation dans
laquelle vous êtes aujourd'hui c'est à
dire pas au pouvoir il faut acter la fin
de l'ump tel qu'il est aujourd'hui ce
que j'avais proposée c'était une
réorganisation avec deux familles nous
allions d'alain juppé à thierry mariani
alain juppé ne trouvait trop à droite
thierry mariani le trouvait trop à
gauche et donc j'avais dit faisons
plutôt deux familles les républicains
libéraux centristes des républicains
patriotes de familles implantées dans
des territoires différents
l'un qui expliquerait en quoi le front
national n'est pas la solution et
l'autre qui expliquait en quoi le je
dirais la macro ni n'est pas
véritablement le centre parce que quand
vous parlez à quelqu'un comme jean
leonetti qui est un vrai centriste
humaniste il vous expliquera en quoi ça
n'est pas un humanisme le maquereau
nisme et est donc simplement quand vous
êtes dans un sous une seule étiquette et
bien forcément les
gérer territoire sont différents les
sujets sont pas les mêmes en vaucluse
moi j'ai suivi agriculture de ruralité
de perdre et services publics de
d'immigration non contrôlée ce sont des
sujets qui sont très différents du 16e
arrondissement de paris ou de la
bretagne donc donc c'est quoi revenir
autant de liberté r d de l'udf c'est oui
mais simplement jeunesse que j'avais
proposée c'est vraiment profité à la
droite la gauche et on a connu deux
parties séparées on a connu un seul
parti unique ce que j'avais proposé à
l'époque c'était deux parties dans une
même famille sur le modèle de la cd ou
et de la cessoie landes là vous acte est
une vraie différence au sein des
républicains est ce que ces deux
familles que vous décrivez seront
capables de se rallier et s'aligner
derrière un seul et même candidat je
réagis bertrand a écrit par exemple
cette semaine aux parlementaires de
droite est ce qu'il est dans son rôle et
est ce que ça peut être la personne
idoine
je pense qu'on peut se rassembler le
nicolas sarkozy était suffisamment
libéral pour les libéraux il avait des
accents bonapartiste qui pesait beaucoup
de listes et en même temps il avait fait
même des mesures quasiment de gauche qui
plaisait aussi elle elle n'a plus la
plus sociale n'ont donc après ses vingt
candidats il vous amène à vous a dépassé
je dirais ces clivages
enfin julien oui moi je suis gaulliste
ça m'empêche pas de m'entendre avec des
centristes des libéraux et même des gens
de gauche et je connais même des
républicains
je dirais de l'autre rive qui partage
sur la souveraineté à 99% ce que je peux
penser donc on n'est pas non plus s'ils
voulaient des robots je crois que il
faut pas dépérir en pensant que parce
qu'on serait dans nos étiquettes et dans
nos cours en politique on serait capable
de dialoguer j'ai beaucoup plus de
choses qui qui me rapproche d'un jardin
monétique et centristes ou d'un libéral
comme nicolas forissier nous avons
beaucoup plus de choses en commun que de
choses en divergence en tout cas c'est
ma conviction et c'est pour ça que je
suis dans ce mouvement et pas dans un
autre et on va parler du reste de
l'actualité on va nous allons parler des
commémorations du bicentenaire de
napoléon cristal mais emmanuel macron
commémore aujourd'hui la mort de
napoléon
est-ce que de votre point de vue il ay
l'arrêt
vous aviez fait des propositions qui
allaient plus ou moins dans ce sens là
oui moi si vous voulez le fondateur du
jeudi l'auteur du code civil du code
pénal la cour des comptes polytechnique
je pense qu'on aurait pu faire un peu
plus voilà moi je suis pour une journée
ne nous semble passer en catimini
et puis et puis vous explique qu'il va
déconstruire déconstruire napoléon a
utilisé le mot c'est à dire il utilise
le mode et des constructeurs bien une
ambiguïté vous avez deux visions
l'histoire vous avez ceux qui comme en
dise la nation est essentielle notre
histoire est essentielle oui des
périodes sombres mais nous devons être
fiers parce que c'est ce qu'ils forment
fait notre ciment et on commémore
napoléon évidemment et puis vous avez
des gens qui détestent ce pays qui
déteste en histoire qui n'aime pas qui
se colorent ce qui vous parle de
l'histoire c'est pour vous rappeler
toujours ce qui est mal année et
pourquoi on devrait être contents et ils
veulent des construire voire effacé
c'est la can cette culture et au milieu
on est à présent la république dit ok je
vais commémorer un peu en catimini sans
public
et puis vous inquiétez pas je vais quand
même déconstruire et 11e en catimini ce
qui fait aujourd'hui une heure sans
public c'est aussi beaucoup enfin la
crise et anita mais il va y va il en a
les divers instituts pour vous c'est
cathy m'rabet vous la grande guerre 1
quand il a fait à son chemin de croix
mémorielle oui lewis et mis en scène
comme le jésus de du drevers guerre
mondiale à laon de citron quand il quand
il veut faire il sait faire croyez moi
donc là il le fait en catimini
c'est dommage moi j'irai remettre une
gerbe
aujourd'hui il s'agit pas de dire que
napoléon était un saint il ya pas de
seins dans l'histoire de france
il s'agit de dire que si j'ai le choix
entre avants napoléon pas dans mon
histoire je suis fier d'avoir napoléon
parce que le monde nous envie napoléon
il nous soyons parfaitement stupide de
dire
veuillez cacher ce bonaparte que je ne
saurais voir parce que de toute façon il
est là et nous lui devons beaucoup de
choses mais on voit bien le sujet qui
cristallise un petit peu aujourd'hui les
débats c'est le rétablissement de
l'esclavagé on sait qu'il va y avoir des
manifestations notamment dans les autres
mers
est ce qu'ils appellent la en sujet
quand même difficile à aborder
onu au nivellement on est célèbre pas
napoléon on commémore les gens
confondent on ne célèbre pas la
rétablissement de l'esclavagé
je veux dire lorsqu'on parle de louis
xiv on ne célèbre pas les morts qu'il a
fait sur les champs de bataille
quand on vous à vous aurez toujours
quand on parle de de gaulle
on ne célèbre pas je dirais la gestion
un peu compliqué la fin de la guerre
avec les harkis on commémore un homme
parce que pour ce qu'il a apporté de
bien au pays voilà et donc si on
commence à prendre tous les personnages
historiques avec les lunettes du 21e
siècle
vous ne trouverez pas une personne qui
passera le filtre parce que même
voltaire qui était anti musulman et
misogyne
je peux vous dire que si je ressourcer
propos vous aurez un tollé donc voilà il
n'y a pas de personnages les personnages
sont dans leur temps ce que je dis
aujourd'hui peut-être que dans 200 ans
les gens dit oh mon dieu mon dieu
comment il pouvait penser ou dire ça
même les plus progressistes faisait de
même qu emmanuel macron dans 200 ans je
passais pas certain que ben est bon et
dans 200 ans de légendes iront jusqu'à
horriblement conservateur bon j'ai créé
salué la qualité
oui la loi climat oui qui a été voté
hier vous avez pour critiquer la
judiciarisation de la vie économique
quitte un peu qui dépend de cette cette
loi est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
aujourd'hui protéger la planète sont
régulés sont loi alors ces deux choses
différentes
protéger la planète sans loi non il faut
évidemment une loi la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on avant de l'écologie
si vous abordez si vous allez vers les
français leur disant l'écologie c'est
l'éco taxe
l'écologie c'est l'écocide l'écologie
c'est je dirais empêcher les entreprises
de fonctionner en leur mettant attention
si vous avez fait une erreur dans un
calcul vous avez on va vous sanctionner
si vous dit de l'écologie s'est tué le
secteur est rien et cetera et cetera et
cetera ou embêter les restaurateurs qui
sont fermés depuis six mois en leur
disant la seule bonne idée mais j'étais
aura eu c'est de fermer d'empêcher
terrasse chauffée
ils peuvent pas travailler quand même et
on leur dit nous on à la seule idée pour
vous aider vous allez l'expliqué ensuite
aux stations de ski qu'on est maintenu
fermé par la mort et ouvrir en décembre
interdit de chant des terrasses
chauffées on arriverait merci une
lichette heures vraiment vous nous avez
pensé à nous donc sa cible et ça ne
fonctionne pas parce qu'on oublie qu'à
un moment donné l'homme j'ai parti de
l'environnement et qu'on doit préserver
l'homme au même titre que la belette
cendres et au même titre que les arbres
et l'homme c'est aussi son travail et sa
vie économique
donc ça gérer que c'est un point de
principe après il ce texte
d'abord je rappelle adopté sans filtre
10% des propositions de la convention
citoyenne ont été adoptés sans fil c'est
à dire hors produits tels quels ça je le
dis en passant pour ceux qui croyaient à
la parole ensuite ce serait faire trop
d'honneur que de lunel l'importance
parce que vous avez des effets
d'affichage
je prends pas attendre les consignes les
gens vont retenir écocide c'est pas un
crime là c'est un délit imaginez si
j'avais dit nous on a créé un délit de
génocide mais parce que les génocides
important et je signe moins important
dans le jeu aussi l'important sera un
crime et puis les gens me gilbert sera
pas bien owen homicide un délit
d'homicide puisque ça il ya des
homicides moins important moi voyez bien
que c'est de la communication et c'est
ça qui tue l'écologie parce que vous
avez des gens qui vont vivre l'écologie
puis ouvrez vous avez des gens qui
veulent vraiment agir moi j'ose que
j'aurais y est c'est qu'est ce qu'on a
fait pour baisser les émissions de co2
est ce que quand on passe des journées
sur les terrasses chauffées
c'est zéro
0 01 % les émissions de co2 mais par
contre un secteur qui souffre
est ce que vraiment on rend service à la
planète moi je le crois pas donc c'est
quoi c'est une loi qui va pas assez loin
c'est une loque est mal ficelé c'est une
loi qui était mal construites parce
qu'en fait c'est une loi ballet avec des
mesures qui semblent importantes et qui
en fait sont très en retrait mais qui
néanmoins suffisamment pointilleuse pour
aller polluer la vie demain des gens il
ya quelques bonnes choses moi la seule
bonne chose que je retiendrai c'est
quand même l'interdiction de la viande
synthétique
je me fais un peu de publicité parce que
c'est francky six auteurs voilà ça c'est
un point positif il ya d'autres points
positifs
je vais pas rentrer non plus voilà tout
n'est pas mauvais mais voyez par exemple
je donne un exemple concret on dit halte
à l'artificialisation des sols et on
vous donne pas la définition
l'artificialisation quand on vous donne
pas l'artificialisation vous disais ça
rentrera en vigueur dans dix ans quand
on aura la définition donnée ne pensais
pas alors les gens vont retenir en
disant c'est super on protège mais on ne
sait pas ce qu'on protège je ne sais pas
quand le froid et merci beaucoup merci
aux verts d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin merci christelle on regarde la
lune de l'année machine appelée ont
faut-il célébrer napoléon c'est à la une
de votre journal merci beaucoup
[Musique]